il y a quelqu'un derrière ce rideau
ah ce rideau
[Rires]
qui est en train de prendre sa douche
non et il y a quelqu'un qui souhaite te
parler
je te jure moi non non ma mère
il y a quelqu'un qui souhaite te parler
tu as aucune idée là pour l'instant 0
franchement je réfléchis mais ça me
vient pas en tête ouais bah ouais je le
vois j'ai pas d'idée vraiment de qui ça
peut être j'ai pas d'idée
tranquillement c'est quoi tes hobbies
c'est quoi tes hobbies
j'ai pas vraiment de hobby enfin j'ai
voilà j'ai pas parce que j'essaie de
réfléchir vraiment et j'ai pas de
d'idées en tête qui me venait où il y a
quelqu'un récemment
avec ton coiffeur
[Applaudissements]
merci regarde le premier indice regarde
on dit souvent loin des yeux loin du
cœur pourtant nous réconciliation est à
quelques centimètres de toi alors ton
cœur arrivera-t-il à se réchauffer alors
c'est toujours les mêmes indices
est-ce que tu commences à avoir une idée
non non toujours pas
la fille qui a parlé je
sais pas
[Musique]
génial non mais elle a dit loin des yeux
loin du cœur pour l'instant il a pas on
a un deuxième indice on a un deuxième
indice pour t'aider d'accord et là je
pense que
tu vas comprendre
un frère
j'avais pas pensé franchement j'avais
pas du tout c'est quoi c'est alors c'est
moi et mon frère
jumeau d'accord tu as un frère jumeau un
frère jumeau mais on est plus trop en
contact ça va faire maintenant depuis à
peu près deux ans et
sincèrement ça fait deux ans mais
sincèrement ça me met pas venu à
l'esprit quoi c'est je pense à lui
pour tout vous dire non non
on va découvrir c'est non regarde
je le reconnais
oui
c'est ton frère
non mais par contre ils m'ont pas fait
venir ici jusqu'au Marseille pour
je suis venu en fait spécialement pour
ah oui il veut te parler alors il veut
te parler tu vas l'écouter
tu vas l'écouter tu vas les écouter
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée lui qui a
envie de te parler il a quelque chose à
te dire
il a mon numéro je comprends pas
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est une belle démarche franchement je
trouve que c'est une belle démarche de
sa part de venir et de te dire ce qu'il
a à te dire devant des millions
téléspectateurs je pense qu'au contraire
tu devrais bien le prendre franchement
c'est très bon alors
je te dis que c'est très beau et il veut
te parler c'est ton frère jumeau il veut
te parler ça fait deux ans que tu as
plus de nouvelles plus de nouvelles non
mais on a toujours eu nos numéros de
téléphone
te dire voilà j'ai envie de te voir là
c'est un geste fort puisque ton frère
jumeau veut te parler s'appelle comment
Yanis d'accord Yanis et là et Yanis a
des choses à dire après tu connais le
principe le principe il y a que la
vérité qui compte qui va revenir c'est
très simple tu vas nous dire est-ce que
tu souhaites ouvrir le rideau une fois
qu'ils t'ont dit qu'il avait à dire ou
bien ce que tu souhaiterais se laisser
le rideau fermé et ne plus avoir de
contact avec lui mais pour le moment je
vais te demander de l'écouter merci en
tout cas d'être là Yan bonsoir Yanis
bonsoir bonsoir Je te donne d'autres
parties à la pub parce que il dit qu'il
veut pas m'entendre attends attends
est-ce qu'on peut régler le son s'il
vous plaît un peu plus correctement
parce que c'est un duplex qui a 2 mètres
donc si vous pouvez mettre
il est juste là hein sinon non je disais
que il disait qu'il voulait pas
m'entendre donc j'étais à d'autres
parties là en fait Yanis je pense que
c'est important que tu lui dises que tu
as ce que tu as à dire à ton frère j'ai
dit que tu avais mon numéro mais juste
prendre le temps de m'écouter prends le
temps de m'écouter et puis me contacter
j'ai réfléchi le temps de m'écouter mais
de m'écouter oh là là
j'ai compris le fait que tu dois
déplacer j'ai compris c'est un bon geste
mais dans tous les cas tu puisses et tu
as mon numéro de téléphone non mais oui
mais c'est pas pareil
c'est pas pareil
c'est bien ce qu'il a à te laisse-le
dire et après tu parleras allez vas-y
vas-y anis dis-lui parce que
tu as peut-être la chance que je
t'écoute parce que moi le rideau je le
tire pas non mais oh
et bien
bon courage chérie de toi qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi vous êtes mouillés
c'est quoi l'histoire mais là
mais c'est qui qui parle Yanis
Yanis vas-y la règle moi déjà là je
viens de base c'était moi la surprise
donc je vois que
la la surprise
ça fait ben voilà ben comme tu sais ça
fait deux ans que on a plus comptable
qu'on se parle plus qu'on fait plus rien
ensemble vous êtes très proche avant
mais oui on est né ensemble on faisait
tous ensemble voilà
très très proche
mais en gros moi j'ai tout fait pour Ben
pour qu'il parle de la maison mettre de
la maison tout simplement donc c'est
vrai que on a fait ça donc là ce soir je
suis là pour aussi reconnaître mes torts
va finir alors oui pourquoi tu as fait
non mais là déjà en fait je prends sur
moi pour pour venir devant tout le monde
dire voilà genre j'ai tort de base voilà
genre juste ne te fous pas de ma gueule
voilà Nice juste qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi tu voulais qu'il parle de
la maison mais parce qu'en fait c'était
toujours tout pour lui toujours pour lui
pour lui pour lui attends attends
laisse-le final laisse-le finir c'est
donc c'était toujours ben pour toi pour
toi tu sais très bien de quoi je parle
de sur tous les sur tous les côtés etc
et donc moi ben on va dire genre je l'ai
poussé voilà à bout j'ai je faisais que
dire par dégage de la maison et jusqu'au
jour en fait il est parti et là je me
dis voilà ben là
honnêtement je me dis le temps passe
vite et tout et là voilà là je viendrai
dans une démarche sincère je me dis en
fait genre c'est l'occasion parce que
c'est vrai que à chaque fois dans la
vraie vie on se dit bah demain demain et
en fait le temps il passe vite et je
pense que toutes les personnes qui ont
des frères et des sœurs et tout ben
voilà je pense pas que la même situation
je regrette mais là quand la direction
comme ça des fois je regrette pas si tu
regardes est-ce qu'il te manque
pour les anniversaires où je me dis ben
je suis seul pour souffler la bougie
alors que de base des frères jumeaux ils
sont censés souffler les bougies
ensemble quoi
attends attends
mais quand je vais vous raconter la
réelle histoire alors bah raconte-nous
la vraie histoire vas-y raconte
donc monsieur il se prend pour une star
il veut pas pour Sean
Pauline oui donc il fait rien le matin
il se lève le matin soit pas si on peut
appeler ça le matin il se lève il faut
pas non mais en fait
je suis pas venu ici
pour que tu racontes ma vie qu'est-ce
que c'est important
de la maison ben parce que j'en avais
marre en fait je m'occupais trop de lui
je lui faisais tout je devais aller lui
faire les courses il refusé d'aller dans
le magasin donc c'est moi qui lui
faisait les courses tu l'aimes c'est ton
frère il te dit qu'il regrette est-ce
qu'il te manque pas un peu moi je sens
qu'il te manque un peu moi quand je vois
maintenant comment je suis bien sans
m'occuper ce petit bonhomme qui se
promène
moi je suis petit bonhomme
je t'explique je suis venu ici c'était
pour qu'on ait une discussion on va
repartir ensemble on va régler nos
problèmes il y a pas de problème mais
non mais surtout il y a pas de problème
mais voilà qu'est-ce que tu souhaiterais
qu'est-ce que tu souhaites mais là
maintenant j'aimerais parler avec lui
mettre les choses à plat et cetera voilà
comme je dis moi au quotidien bah il me
manque quand même à chaque fois je me
dis ben qu'est-ce qui peut bien faire et
tout quand même là je veux dire mais
pour les anniversaires pour les fêtes
etc c'est extrêmement beaucoup pour les
anniversaires
l'anniversaire
le 7 août ah bah c'est bien c'est pas de
si loin donc anniversaire Noël le jour
de l'an tout ce qu'il faut non non mais
par contre quand il faut se bouger le
petit doigt pour aller ben en fait comme
on dit rentrer dans la vie active mais
il y a plus personne
comme d'habitude en fait
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours
prends le temps de comprendre genre
voilà genre toi aussi tu as eu mon
numéro toi aussi tu aurais pu m'appeler
genre au bout d'un moment voilà
c'est bon là voilà genre s'il te plaît
moi j'ai pas demandé à t'appeler alors
attends
mais non mais donc je pars non non
qu'est-ce que je dois dire pourquoi je
suis là non mais attends attends et toi
c'était une surprise ah parce que
c'était ça
[Applaudissements]
une très belle surprise et c'est fort
moi Nessim moi je trouve que ce que tu
as fait ici c'est un autre pote ici
il y a 10 il y a 10 moi je trouve que ce
que tu as fait c'est très fort parce que
franchement c'est très courageux ce soir
devant les caméras de le dire en direct
hein Laurent toi qui est spécialiste
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
moi je suis père de jumelles Jean-Marie
connaît le même problème et on voit le
même problème la même qualité d'avoir
des jumeaux et on sait que les jumeaux
c'est super fort comment tu expliques
que depuis deux ans tu as cette réaction
ce soir alors tu n'as pas eu depuis 2
ans et qui vient gentiment ouvrir son
cœur ouais parce qu'en fait même pour la
réalité pour tout vous dire
sincèrement là quand on a commencé
l'émission j'ai même pas du tout pensé à
ça et ça me venait pas l'esprit mais
deux ans c'est vrai que c'est passé vite
c'était même après mais 22 un frère
jumeau quoi un frère jumeau
Yanis toi tu aimerais que vous vous
retrouviez
et que vous renouillez des liens oui
voilà
très proche voilà on faisait toujours
frère d'ailleurs jumeaux en plus comme a
dit Laurent jumeau c'est un truc de fou
voilà on faisait voilà en fait on
faisait tout ensemble
pourquoi il te manque le plus des
anniversaires
[Rires]
non mais c'est que genre avoir quelqu'un
sur qui compter même c'est qui je
remette beaucoup et tout et c'est vrai
que là j'ai dû non mais je dis ça ça te
fait quelque chose de le revoir ou pas
mais là honnêtement je le vois pas je
sais pas où il est je l'entends
[Applaudissements]
je m'attendais pas à ça pour le Mondial
de la coiffure
on a compris
que tu étais là c'est bon mais genre tu
veux une surprise genre c'est bon je
suis là c'est quand même ouais c'est
énorme
[Applaudissements]
tu peux le voir tu peux juste le voir
[Musique]
ce que je pensais pas qu'il était aussi
loin mais par contre voilà
malheureusement
tu dis rien pour l'instant
tu ne dis rien pour l'instant
ça me fait de la peine
honnêtement je n'ai pas les mots je sais
pas à quoi ils se comprend il croise les
convenait au spectacle mais pas du tout
là genre là là je suis dans une démarche
vraiment sincère et bien sûr je suis là
pour arranger les choses lui il est là
il me refont le rideau comme ça je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi
franchement je trouve que là je trouve
que oui ça non oui ça oui attends
attends attends parce que là je trouve
que là il faut il faut que tu te calmes
2 minutes qui sont venus et que tu
comprennes mon frère et que à un moment
de ce que vous m'avez raconté c'est pas
des histoires de fou non plus ça va
c'est pas non plus dramatique ce qu'il
t'a fait donc là il y a ton frère qui
vient qui fait la démarche qui nous dit
je veux reparlerai mon frère je regrette
ce que j'ai fait j'aimerais renouer des
liens avec lui non non non
il y a plusieurs voilà il y a plusieurs
situations que peut-être tu peux
comprendre qu'ils veulent pas me
pardonner mais je veux dire voilà je
vais pas tout raconter ici et voilà
exemple c'est que voilà genre la tartine
au caca c'était moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
on était bon c'était c'était un très
longtemps c'était pas il y a 2 ans
c'était donc avant le confinement quand
tout le monde pouvait sortir on est on a
en fait on s'est fait un camping et le
soir ont été faites des un apéro avec
des chips des bonbons des gâteaux et on
avait fait des tortues Nutella et en
fait on a un petit enfin il a un petit
chien qui est très joli d'ailleurs mais
il déverse toutes sortes de choses de
partout voilà bon il a fait caca et lui
bah du coup là je viens d'apprendre ça
il m'a il m'a mis ça dans la tartine et
pendant une pendant une heure on
cherchait qui m'a fait ça mais bien sûr
c'était personne
et là je vais t'apprendre donc c'est ça
la surprise
[Applaudissements]
parce que franchement il faut avoir
alors mais attends attends venir ici non
mais il regrette il regrette il regrette
est-ce que tu peux nous dire un autre
truc que tu regrettes
ah oui tant mieux
ils sont mignons
mais c'était moi qui a fait la connerie
et en fait
alors
c'est pas grave mais c'est bon
s'il te plaît donc tu as quitté la
maison tu ne voyais plus ton frère
depuis deux ans et ce soir Yanis a eu le
courage
c'est l'avenir ici parler en direct et
de te dire qu'il regrettait tout ce
qu'il avait fait tout ce qui avait fait
que tu avais quitté la maison et
qu'aujourd'hui tu lui manquais notamment
pour les anniversaires
ce que vous vous êtes né le même jour
forcément il le fait tout seul et
il y a nice aujourd'hui j'aimerais que
sans que tu parles ils te dise une
dernière chose qui te résume tout ça et
tu décideras ensuite si tu veux ouvrir
le rideau peut-être
repartir avec ton frère et le retrouver
et que vous puissiez discuter tous les
deux et peut-être à ranger les choses et
vous retrouver comme avant ou bien tu me
diras non je ne veux pas ouvrir le
rideau Cyril j'ai envie de rester seul
avec mes problèmes capillaires et
je pars sur autre chose
là depuis un petit moment quoi depuis la
pause publique et tout je cogite je
réfléchis et je me dis est-ce que j'ai
bien fait de venir à très bien fait à
très bien fait voilà donc vraiment
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
aujourd'hui maintenant de
peut-être pas sur le plateau mais plus
tard tout à l'heure de discuter de tout
mettre à plat et moi je suis prêt à
prendre un peu sur moi un peu
beaucoup beaucoup
et vraiment je regrette toutes les
actions passées et je veux même que tu
reviennes à la maison si tu es d'accord
c'est beau
alors
oui ça
je vais te laisser
30 secondes
pour réfléchir tu es seul
je ne t'ai plus de parler tu réfléchis
tu remets tout ça dans ta tête et tu me
dis oui je veux ouvrir le rideau
et aller peut-être retrouver mon frère
est repartir avec lui ou non ou bien tu
me dis non
j'ai envie de retrouver personne et
d'aller me rasseoir à côté de Sergio
[Rires]
est parti en Ramadan aller manger je
pense ça reviendra bien entendu après
manger dans deux jours
Yanis
et oui Sam ça va jouer maintenant oui
Sam je te laisse 30 secondes
[Musique]
je ne te parle plus
malheureusement ça va en décevoir
certains qui attendaient le fait que
j'ouvre moi-même le rideau mais
enfin pour tout vous dire je réfléchis
encore mais
un peu de temps t'inquiète pas il y a
Bruce le derrière c'est pas grave on
peut le décaler il est décédé
donc prends encore 30 secondes pour
réfléchir
et tu reviens avec nous tu reviens vers
moi dans 30 secondes
je me sens mal je vais pas réfléchir
plus longtemps parce qu'en réalité j'ai
pris ma décision
et je vais pas ouvrir le rideau pourquoi
c'est une blague parce que
non il va pas ouvrir tu te fous de ma
gueule
pour venir tu me fais ça j'aurais pas
avec toi maintenant tu as compris le
rideau ou c'est moi je comprends pas
[Applaudissements]
je comprends pas tu me dis t'ouvrir le
rideau toi ou c'est moi qui choisis
alors tu es content de le voir ou pas
content peut-être pas mais
pas tu es content de le voir
en tout cas c'est très beau ce que tu as
fait tu vois un câlin
non mais est-ce que alors on va faire
une nouvelle formule
non mais moi je viens de Marseille
jusqu'à ici
donc là
en fait
toi j'ai décidé de ne pas ouvrir le
rideau
je suis désolé mais avec moi
allez allez moi je t'ai dit avec moi
allez Yanis allez tu repars avec moi
c'est quoi non mais c'est quoi
allez non mais attends
parler je crois que c'est un Skype
elle est pas mal cette nouvelle version
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors attends alors attends donc il y a
des règles il y a des règles
retourne à la rideau retourne
là
donc tu veux tu vas aller voir
finalement
je vais aller le voir c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]